after being married for thirty years we
got divorced maybe nine years later we
got back together and then a few years
after that we got married again and we
were happier than ever we met each other
in summer stock he was playing Billy
Bigelow in carousel and I was playing
Carey pepperidge was comedian
[Music]
this sounds over-the-top but it was
almost as though like you see those
special effects in the movie where
everything kind of goes dark and there's
just a light on this one person and
that's the way this woman hit me we just
connected it was wonderful Elizabeth
sang before me and she was really good
which was a great relief because I was
already struck by this woman but you
know you're an actor and a singer and
show business and if the person you fall
in love with is a singer and they're not
any good you got a problem and he was a
wonderful singer just fabulous singer I
was so impressed I sang that better than
I ever sang it before or since
knowing that Betsey Hepburn was sitting
outside listening to me sing I found out
later that I really blew her socks off I
liked him and he was I mean he was he
was on my case every day I asked her out
for dinner and every day she had to wash
her hair it was interesting I was dating
someone named Ben at the time I was
getting ready after rehearsal one day to
drive my Vespa into town to the
laundromat and do some laundry and she
said oh are you gonna do the laundry I
said yeah she says I've got some laundry
I said come along so our first date was
at a laundromat in Lebanon Pennsylvania
he said to me I feel like I know you I
just had this feeling that I knew her I
can't explain it my eyes rolled and we
came back to the city separately but as
soon as I was in my apartment he was
about three weeks later we finally said
well yes he said I guess we should get
married I said yes
I guess so we were extremely compatible
so we got married
and the rest that's when the games begin
she went about her career I went about
mine so we were doing fine and then I
got sick whoa you really made your
big-time sick I had to have a kidney out
I mean brauch and I had to have
chemotherapy after that and it was like
a big seven-year event I really got into
spirit I got better I got totally better
and there were you know they gave me
five years to live that was a long time
yeah went through a number of health
crises which she from which he emerged
you know Ben and me that that first bout
was with cancer was very very hard on
him and he didn't have a clue of buddy
but he was good he was stood by me and
he was he was there after we had been
married for 25 years or so things
started getting a little funky and I
can't really put my finger on it even
now I can't be real explicit about what
happened I know I had started a business
and it wasn't making any money Ben and I
had a very difficult period and I ended
up leaving this was without a doubt the
low point of my life I was I was very
distressed and very upset for a long
time I went into therapy and I mean my
heart was broken I mean I couldn't
believe that I was I was leaving my
marriage what happened to me was a loss
of self-esteem when the person that
knows you best that is the center of
your life decides they do not want do
not want to be with you anymore it's
really tough on your self-esteem I
really started feeling like I was a
worthless piece of crap it was it was
just the saddest thing I ever did and
yet I knew I had to do it I'm all about
heart I'm all about sharing my heart I'm
all about sharing love and I got so sad
about whatever was happening to us and
it was almost inexplicable to me but I
I I couldn't feel the love in my heart
anymore my life was a shambles my
friends kept fixing me up on dates and I
went out with a lot of very attractive
women none of them interested me in the
least I think you could say that we were
apart for like six years what happened
with her was 9/11 I had to gather
everyone that I loved to my heart
everybody in my life she started
thinking about the people that really
meant the most to her in her life and
wanting to bring them close and I was on
the top of that list he was right there
at the front of the lot and we started
dating if you were one of a better term
so we we started going to the movies and
seeing each other and taking walks in
the park and I don't know how to
describe it it was awkward but yet it
wasn't it it it was Ben probably told
you about my better and better series
one of the projects I had was something
that Elizabeth had written and it
ultimately came to be known as the
better and better series and it was a
series of videos to support surgery
patients to help people get relaxed and
feel secure before surgery and so then
Elizabeth and I not only were we dating
but we were working together
on a joint project I was the director
and editor
she was the presenter of the writer and
the singer I think it was in early June
of 2005 she said I think it's time for
me to move back in well I can't tell you
how wonderful that felt two or three
years later she said maybe we should get
married it was the most beautiful day I
was like a summer day so that was as of
this moment 19 years ago I jokingly say
that I like my second wife a lot but I
like my first wife and she says the same
thing about her second husband he's very
good to me and we've been together for
long having experienced the loss of this
person who was the center of my life and
then having gotten her back again
there's really nothing that I wouldn't
do to preserve that relationship and to
support that relationship
there he is
hello your friend in mind these boys
been nice to you
oh very nice I have no idea what she
told you probably all lies but I hope
that it inspires some people that that
have broken up and want to get back
together that it's possible to do it and
I'm certainly glad we did it well I'm
glad we did it too when I left it wasn't
like I couldn't wait to get out there
and start dating and you know get into
it I couldn't hear my soul I couldn't
hear my muse anymore I wasn't writing I
wasn't singing I wasn't doing and I knew
that I had to sort of reconnect with
those and that's that's that was one of
the main reasons I left the end is never
the end I mean there's you know life is
filled with new beginnings I know people
that turn 65 and they think they're old
and they're ready to give up well I'm 83
and I haven't gotten here yet you know
and I don't intend to I've been told my
whole life to act my age never did it
still don't thank you very much
[Music]